uh good evening
members
uh officers um ladies and gentlemen um i
don't think we have any members of the
press welcome to this planning committee
meeting on the 17th of november
i always have a few housekeeping rules
which i would ask you i know the members
are aware of these but members of the
public
um
i have to give these out so
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs
either through the security
door which is
to my
right and your left and down the stairs
otherwise use the corridor that you came
through
turn sharp left and use the stairs which
will take you down to the ground floor
please do not use the lifts
symbol in holy square on the green
and an officer if appropriate will tell
you and
bring you back over to this building in
the chamber to continue the committee
meeting
is there anyone here this evening going
to film
our meeting at all
i can't see any hands thank you for that
i will remind you that we are being live
streamed on the council youtube channel
and following this meeting this evening
you can have another look at us if you
wish to because it is recorded as well
thank you for that
i also would like to advise members to
turn off and members of the public turn
off their mobile phones and please do
not take calls or make calls while this
meeting is in
progress
thank you
members requesting to speak under
council procedure 20.1
uh i have counselor town in on item 4c
is that thank you councillor towning are
there any other members who
i can't see you
no thank you very much
public speaking the public foreign
empire applications have been reserved
for public speaking with members please
note
that speaking on the agenda for the
gender is item 5d
3 viking close burchington and item 5c
17 northumberland avenue
margate
agenda item 1 i have apologies for
absence uh
from councillor hopkinson
and councilman alan curry including
councillor curry once again
uh who has taken hopkinson's place
i also am aware that councillor joel
bayford
is absent tonight just for members
if i may um
most members know that
council bob bayford has been
pretty poorly in a london hospital
um
and she has gone up to pick him up today
which uh i'm sure members like myself
wish him
a speedy recovery i know he's gone
through a pretty bad time
thank you that for councilwoman
uh item two gender item two are there
any declarations of interest
i don't see any thank you
agenda item three minutes of the
planning committee held on the 20th of
october the members agree that the
minutes of that meeting
are all
okay and could i if they do could i have
a proposal please
thank you councillor hart seconded
by
thank you councillor
i got me wrong glasses on tonight so
bear with me
do you all agree
thank you
agenda item for
is uh
seagulls uh cliff promenade broadstairs
i will now ask the planet officer to
outline this report please
excuse me thank you chair
um
this is the application site for
seagulls
and members may recall the application
and it's for the erection of a
three-story building containing eight
two-bedroom self-contained flats
and it was discussed
at september's planning committee
and at that meeting was deferred to
officers for further information in
relation to stability
in relation to the creation of the
undercroft parking and cliff erosion
generally
so i'll just remind members before going
on to discuss um what it was deferred to
just of the application generally so as
i say this is the application site
outlined in red
so this is the aerial photo photograph
of the site and surrounding areas so the
site is again outlined in red we have
wayfaring to the right here
and huckle to the left
and so we have some photographs now the
application site is centrally located
here
this is wayfaring and hucklo
this shows the application site to the
left of the um photograph
and wayfaring
and this is looking the other way so
you've had chloe
oh sorry
bear with me huckle
sorry going the wrong way hup club is
this
roof you can see here
so this is looking from cliff promenade
at the front of the existing seagulls
building
this is to the rear
of the site
and this is the rear showing
uh the relationship currently of the
current building with hutclo on the
right hand side and this is the other
relationship with the existing building
edge here and that's wayfaring to the
left
as members may also recall from the
september meeting the scheme has was
that they considered in september was an
amended scheme from where it originally
came in so this was a scheme in its
original submission so the existing
street scene is at the top here and this
was a scheme when it first came into
members but not the scheme that was
considered by members
at the meeting
in september
this is the scheme that's now being
considered and what
what members looked at in september so
this is the front elevation here
and you can see the neighbouring
building so
uh wayfairing and huckle on the
left-hand side
this is the side elevation you can see
the three stories plus the undercroft
parking
we have the rear elevation at the top
here and the other flank elevation
this is the underground car parking
basement
and it has provision for 10 spaces
this is the ground floor and it's
essentially the
two bottom floors so the ground and firs
full have three flats in within them so
one running along the rear one here and
one to the other side
uh the first floor plan mirrors
the floor plan below
and this is the second floor
and it has two flats running essentially
along the rear with some decking in this
location here
and that sort of plan for this site has
proposed
so officers um consider the building is
not is well designed following the
amendments that have been secured
throughout the application process
and is in keeping with the scale of
surrounding buildings
it utilizes materials found within the
area so that is considered
a welcome
addition to it and it adds to the
variety of the properties that are found
in north orland estate in generally
it's not considered as an adverse impact
on the living conditions of surrounding
occupants occupiers or highways given
that there will be on-site provision for
ten spaces and there is on-street
parking available
in the road
and returning now to issues raised
about stability for the evac for the car
parking basement and cliff stability in
general
there there was a plan submitted and i
understand it was actually part of the
agenda so members have seen this
plan which was submitted by the
applicant setting out how they would
that's setting out the detail of the
construction of the basement
is sequentially and the details of the
digs that would be required for the
basement area to be constructed
they advised the
excavation would be would in fact be
well away from the cliff edge
and it would be separated from the road
and then also some distance to the
actual cliff edge itself
and also it is
partly on made ground which is land
that's been raised when the
in the front garden from when they
excavated the swimming pool to the rear
of the site and they also advised that
they would that secant piles would board
for the board for the perimeter of the
basement box before that any excavation
actually would take place
and that would ensure stability and if
necessary when the excavation works for
being take taking place a ground
penetrating radar survey could be
carried out and that should be
that should secure stability of that
basement excavation and officers
consider that is acceptable
in terms of cliff stability there is a
policy cco free of the local plan which
relates to coastal development
and this actually triggers
um on land within 40 meters of the cliff
top
this development we're considering at
seagulls is some 45 meters away from the
cliff top at its close at its closest
point
but we have however at the instruction
of members sought advice from the
council's a technical deputy technical
services manager
and he advises that cliff erosion at
north forland is currently slow and is
approximately 100 millimeters per year
so given this and the further details
submitted about the basement
um
excavation works and how they would be
carried out office do con officers
consider there are no there wouldn't be
an impact on land stability from this
application
so office the officer recommendation
is as it was in september to defer and
delegate to officers for the receipt of
the undertaking for the sam contribution
thank you chair
thank you annabelle i move the officer's
recommendation is adopted because the
vice chair please second oh second
nature
thank you council common cook members do
you wish to debate this
casagana
thank you um yeah thanks for the um
updated report um
i obviously
personally can't claim to be
a technical
excavation expert um so
i have to take on board what what has
been stated by the deputy technical
services
officer i think you said i mean i do
have issues with some of the
um statements that have been made
um i have i accept
what you say about um
a 10 centimeter erosion
recently but it's also stated in the
report that has reduced i'm not sure
over what period of time that was
measured
because it also states in the report
that in the previous year there was
significant erosion
i think it depends on what the
the um
conditions like the weather and
we've had quite a decent spell of
weather and some of the erosion has
reduced but the year before there was
still more stormy weather and there was
more significant erosion and i think
it's a generally accepted
um fact
that as
the climate warms the
sea level will rise there will be more
high tides against that cliff
and there will be significantly more
erosion
now obviously
that doesn't
if there is more significant erosion on
that cliff that isn't just gonna ex
going to impact this one building
because there are a number of other
buildings
along there
and
um obviously at my age if i owned one of
them buildings i would like to think
that maybe it wouldn't affect me living
there but my children if they were
living there
might be wanting to sell pretty quickly
um
once i've gone but no that's by the buy
i just wanted to make sure that people
understood that actually
you know
if we're relying on 10 centimeters of
cliff erosion every year for the next 50
years then i think we're we're certainly
barking up the wrong tree it's going to
get worse than that
the other thing i wanted to raise
at the la when this was discussed at the
september meeting
although we did
have a number of different concerns
about cliff erosion and the underground
excavation there were
quite a number of other concerns that
were raised by by us
as to why
we
by some of us anyway
um were not in favor of this application
and some of those were raised by both
the broadstairs society and broadstairs
town council about the this being
a development out of keeping with the
surrounding area and being against the
um
you know the broad state the recently
adopted
um broad stairs neighbourhood plan so i
don't i hope that we won't be just
discussing and debating and accepting
this just on this engineer's report
because i know a number of others of us
had other concerns
that um
we we might want to consider before we
before we approve or otherwise this
application
thank you
uh thank you counselor ghana um
members uh
i don't
cancer auburn
yeah thank you chair uh i wasn't here
for the last meeting and i'm thinking i
shouldn't say anything but um
i just want to take up a point in
account that counselor ghana made
in relation to the design of the
building
um
i know the area
quite well and over the last
10 15 years there's been a number of new
developments within that private that
private estate
that
could actually mirror this
um so i don't think that the design
issue
stands up there are a number of
different designer buildings some very
old some newest and i can't see a
problem at all with the actual design
chair thank you
thank you for that council robin
okay members
no any other counselors i can't see any
accounts with their hand
okay members thank you for that um i'm
going to put this to yourselves
uh
the recommendation is to defer and
delegate
for those show the hands who are in
favor please
those against
abstentions
thank you america that is carried and
that's myself as well thank you members
for that
moving on to agenda item five the
schedule of planning applications and
public speaking
if there are any site visits as i think
members are aware we are sort of back to
normal as i speak tonight
they will take place on friday the 3rd
of december 2021
agenda item 5b is a planning application
for approval
at number three viking close birchington
uh speaking in favor of the application
is mr jackson
mr jackson are you there good evening
chair good evening you have three
minutes thank you jackson um our clients
asked us to speak tonight to clear up a
few misconceptions regarding this
variation of condition application
and some of the items raised in
objections
firstly with regard to condition five
and the choice of brick the hoskin
lithium 45 was selected by the client
from the outset it was used in all of
the drawings and 3d visualizations for
the original application
and details of this brick were provided
to the planning officer during the
course of the application and prior to
determination
unfortunately this was not picked up in
the decision notice which instead
referenced the generic buff brick which
was initially noted on the application
form although slightly darker in tone
than the buff brick the lithium 45 is a
highly attractive choice and very
suitable for a contemporary building
such as this
it's important to keep in mind that the
client was careful to consult all of his
adjoining neighbours prior to submission
all of whom confirmed that they were
fully in support of his design and
materials choices
this is reflected by the nine letters
received in support of the applica of
the original application and the 20
letters received in support of this
variation of condition application
had there been any doubt about the
specific nature of the proposed break a
materials condition could have been
added to the original decision notice
which would have enabled us to avoid any
need for enforcement on this matter
regarding condition three details of
proposed cycle parking were requested
on the original application consent
despite this information being clearly
annotated on the originally submitted
and approved drawings therefore we've
been required to include this item for
removal of condition as part of section
73.
lastly regarding condition two
and the height of the boundary walls
the proposed height increase to the
boundary walls relates to walls within
the site
between the application site and the
neighbor's properties not around the
cartilage or the outside of the site and
it will therefore have no impact on the
appearance of the development from the
surrounding area
the increase in height is relatively
modest but it will enable a far cleaner
relationship with the adjacent garage to
number two and it will screen that flank
uh elevation of the garage and the roof
detail
again it is important to keep in mind
that the client has previously consulted
his adjoining neighbours on this matter
prior to the application all of whom
were fully in agreement of the proposed
wall height agreed in agreement with the
proposed material the brick and fully in
support of the application indeed some
have even paid towards the construction
of this wall
i hope this clarifies some of the issues
surrounding the application and thank
the committee for their time this
evening
thank you mr jackson i will ask mr
livingston
our planning officer to read out his
report thank you
thank you chair
um so the application is a variation of
condition application um
under
section 73 of the planning act in
relation to the approval that
for the application that members looked
at
in april
which was for the erection of a dwelling
house
in replacement of the existing bungalow
so in the center of the aerial image
you'll see the previous bungalow
that was in situ at this site adjacent
to the open space
this was the approved
design that came through
and as has just been outlined there are
a few changes that have been made uh to
clear up some of the um
the the issues that have come up with
the scheme so
just have a little look this is a
visualization that was produced as
mentioned showing the brick but as
identified the details that were
submitted on the application form
indicated that the brick on the ground
floor would be a
buff multi-stock brick
um the dwelling
that's then been constructed
so far and the proposal that's with us
this evening is to change the brick to a
a grey brick which you can see obviously
on the ground floor so
the ground floor is is the brick element
the upper floors are um are others
rendered elements which are which are
lighter
so just go to go around some of the
photos of the property at the moment
um so you've got uh just another view
here in relation to number two viking
close
you've then got the side wall which
we'll come back to in a bit
and then looking back towards the side
wall looking back towards the open space
and then the further out view of the
development just showing the site in its
context
this is an image just showing opposite
the site the other side of the green
just showing the variety of designs of
properties but also the variety of
materials that's found in the area and
the report identifies some of the
different types of materials that you
can find in the vicinity of this site
so this is the approved front elevation
of the property um if i can ask members
to have a little look where the mouse
pointer is between number two and number
three i just want to show the difference
in terms of the boundary walls
that are proposed so as outlined in the
report that there was a two meter high
wall to the boundary with number two
uh that's being increased to what 2.45
meters in height
that increase in height is happening
adjacent to the garage of number two so
it's not considered there's any impact
on residents of number two
then just looking at the rear of the
building so that increased boundary wall
height is on the right hand side of that
image so that's the proposed plan
showing the height
um then looking at the side elevation so
this is if you're
at number two
looking uh back towards the the site um
so you can see the back of the wall
here
and then
just going to the
landscaping
so
what has also changed as a result of
this application is a slight variation
in the position of of the gates and
slight changes to the landscaping at the
rear as well as the rear wall
uh which obviously goes onto the
neighbors on on minis road it is
increasing by um
from 2.3 to 2.4
and given the location of that it's not
considered that increases is significant
at all
um so i'll just if i click through then
you'll see
that the the gate has changed slightly
there's slight change to the landscaping
but nothing to impact on the overall
visual impact of the development in the
area
so just to confirm the other point
as mentioned the annotation
is on the plan showing that cycle
storage is contained within the garage
so it's not considered this condition
which was placed on the original consent
is necessary because the site has clear
ability to have cycle storage in that
garage
so
one of the issues that's come up that
just wanted to address within the the
the representations that have come in
relates to the boundary um of this
property with um the open space so this
is a map just to confirm
the council ownership of the actual
green itself but not of this side access
way where the mouse point is going up
and down
what you can see here is that there is a
slight dog leg out in the boundary on
using the council's os plan
which is also shown on the original site
location plan
um and and obviously that is a boundary
that has simply been replaced uh where
it was uh with the new construction so
it's not considered that that
you know that has changed at all from
the original submission so it's not
something that's been considered within
this uh variation
so overall uh the changes are not
considered to water down the previous
permission that's been granted or cause
any um adverse impact on the character
appearance of the area or indeed
neighbours it is considered there's
sufficient variation of material in the
area that this doesn't appear out of
keeping
and therefore the application is
recommended for approval thank you chair
uh thank you
i move the officer's recommendation is
adopted could the vice chair please
second oh second you two thank you
councillor coleman cook
members
councilor keane
thank you chair uh just a question about
the boundary wall why was the height of
that increase do you know
okay
um no i don't have the information as to
why in terms of the boundary wall at the
side which has increased by the most by
the 0.4 but in terms of the
considerations it's it's really about
the one is the visual impact and the
second bit would be obviously impact on
that neighbor and in fact on the image
on the screen um you can see where that
the garage is on the side which means
that the nearest habitable room window
in the neighboring property is set away
by the width of the garage so that
increase of 0.4 isn't considered to be
problematic plus if i go back to the
images
um
you can see that there is a slight there
is the the land level drops down um so
if i go
to
this image here you can see the land
level of the green is a bit higher than
the actual land level of the property so
on a visual impact terms it's not
considered there's a wider harm from the
increase in height of that wall um you
know in the vicinity of the green simply
because of the context that it's in
thank you accounts for alban
yeah thank you chair um i suppose the
main issue really uh is the uh
the material
um in the the
ground floor
and personally i quite like it i think
it's uh
i think it's
doesn't detract from anywhere
um and i think the other issues about
the walls
are
very minor
and i'll be supporting this chair thank
you
thank you council robin members
any other hands raised
no thank you so once again i put this to
yourselves
members if you show hands who are in
favor
please show
those against
abstentions
members thank you that has been carried
thank you
okay uh agenda item
5c
is the planning application for approval
number 17 at northumberland avenue
margate
speaking and raising points of concerns
i think mr brown knows how long he's got
mr brown
thank you chairman i'm speaking on
behalf of three neighbours uh the three
neighbors that all are adjacent to this
site and want to cover three issues if i
can street scene
neighbour impact and consultation
starting with street scene the immediate
street scene here has hardly changed
since it was built brick elevations and
hipped roofs with some tile and rendered
detail predominate
there have been some changes made that
did not require planning permission but
no other material changes
this proposal introduces gable roofs to
both side and rear elevations and clads
the building in cedric cladding which is
not present in the immediate street
scene
the loss of space between buildings
introduction of gable ends and use of
cladding are all out of character with
the street scene when viewed from the
opposite side of the road
now on to neighbour impact
the proposal changes a demeanor
diminutive single-story bungalow into a
two-story house
with a large rear door
and rear windows overlooking neighbours
the erection of the dormer is only
possible because of the roof height
being increased the officer report is
therefore wrong to state that the dormer
could be carried out as permitted
development
the bulk and depth of the two-story
extensions to either side of the
existing bungalow also affects the
outlook from two neighbours either side
of the application site
both neighbours have existing side
windows the proposed extensions will
reduce light too and outlook from those
side windows which serve habitable rooms
and finally on to consultation
the mppf encourages pre-apple
consultation and clear notification of
the proposal by the local planning
authority
this is a close-knit community who had
no idea of the proposed extensions until
they were notified by the planning
authority
the notification letter had an incorrect
description which further misled the
neighbours
the neighbours had to get a consultant
involved to point this out resulting in
further notification to clarify that the
proposal involved two-story development
and an increase in the height of the
building
it was only then that they were aware of
the extent of the development
this has been made worse by the fact
that no one from the planning offices
visited the objectors properties to
assess the impact of the scheme when
viewed from their gardens
surely an essential requirement when
assessing this proposal
the objectives therefore request that
planning commission visit the gardens as
part of a site visit to see the extent
of the development and its impact upon
the street scene and neighbour immunity
prior to determining the application
thank you chairman
thank you mr brown uh speaking as ward
councillor a council of towning
thank you chair
good evening committee
um
i have been
contacted by as a local councillor by
three of the neighbors
to the application application side
it is unusual for a group of
neighborhoods to
get together like this
and show the level of of just stress
they have
they they were all aware that
they were all unaware of the proposed
development until the planning
application was made and misled by the
initial description
when
it was clear that the extent of the
scheme was
they contacted me and appointed a
consultant to represent them
the application proposed proposal
changed the existing small bungalow
similar to number 15 into a two-story
house
the building extends to the back and the
side remove removing the hip roof
and leaves the open space
at the at the first floor level to the
gable
that enclosed those spaces
this
has the effect of the damaging the
street scene and losing the daylight and
and overlooking all three properties
number 19 northumberland
has a side window on the ground floor
and first floor level that will lose
light and overlook
because of the gable wall
close to their boundary and the rear
flat roof dormer
number 11 lonsdale has a side garden
that runs along the back of the
applicant's application property
this will lose its privacy
because the windows the new windows and
the doors overlook its garden
number 15 launcher will
a large
a large extension running beyond its
side elevation close to the south
boundary resulting in the loss of
outlook and
sunlight
i asked you councillors
to hold a site meeting to assess
these concerns themselves
as the case officer did not visit
their properties as part of the site
assessment
because of the lack of consultation
provision of a provision of an incorrect
notification letter
and the lack of vision a visit of the of
the planning officer
i feel it's the least these people can
be afforded
thank you
thank you councillor town in an ask our
planning officer annabelle to outline
her report
thank you chair
so this is the application site outlined
in red number 17.
this is number 15 and number 19 and this
is number 11 lonsdale avenue which has
its rear garden running along
behind number 17 and number 15.
so this is an aerial
view of the site in the surrounding area
so this is number 17
this is number 11 with its rear garden
and numbers 19 and numbers 15.
and this is standing in northumberland
avenue so this is the application site
here this is number 15. you can see a
side doorman with some windows there
and number 19 as you can see is a
two-story uh property
and with an outbuilding
um in between that and number 17.
this photograph is from inside the
application site
and it's looking towards the rear of the
garage of number
17 sorry and the boundary in the photo
that you can see on the right hand side
is between numbers 17 and number 15.
this is again
inside the rear garden of number 17
and that that's number 15 you can see
there with the side door and the windows
within that dormer
and this again is in the rear garden
so you can see the rear elevation of
numbers 17 as it stands now and you can
see
to the side of it the dormer window of
number 15.
um this is
the rear elevation and behind of number
17 you can see number 19 to the
left-hand side of the photo
and this is another view of the
relationship between number 17
and number 19 you can see the roof of
the outbuilding that sits between
the two properties but it's an ad out
buildings excuse me for number 19.
so this block plan gives
you can see the hatch areas actually
show where the applications
the property is being extended
so this is the existing front elevation
that we've just seen the garage here
and this is a proposed front elevation
so you can see
the roof um
changing form here and being lifted up
it is correct that there is
um some uniformity of the street scene
on this side of the road but there is
variety
further along in the street scene so
it's not considered that this changing
roof form would be detrimental
significantly detrimental to character
and appearance of the area because there
is variety
more generally as you look up along the
road
and just for information the the height
of the roof that's been um is being
increased by
0.5 meters
this is side elevation facing number 15
as existing
and this is it as proposed you can see
again the changes in the roof
are there
this is the side facing
number 19
and again that's
the
elevationist post and you can see the
flat roof dormer coming into play here
the rear elevation is existing
and the rear
elevation has proposed so this is the
dormers here
this isn't actually an ensuite
window and these are two bedroom windows
and we'll look at the floor plans in a
bit
so that there is um
considerations that members need to make
in the on the basis the fact that if
number 17 as it currently stands is a
single story dwelling
it does not have windows therefore at
first floor level
and to the rear
but it is considered
that
a dormer could be placed there
under permitted development and it could
contain windows and it is set out in the
report that that couldn't be done
with the roof being raised but it could
be done with the roof
remaining at the same height but a
dormer could go there so there is a full
back position for members
to think about there
looking at the position of the rear
windows as i said the two of the juliet
balconies are bedroom windows
so it's anticipated they would be clear
glazed it is not considered that there
would be
a direct view from those windows
into the gardens of number 19 or number
15
given that their angles and
there might be a very slight angled view
of the corners of those gardens
the garden of number 11 lonsdale avenue
as we stated runs along is located here
so it runs to the rear of
number 15 and number sorry number 17 the
number 15.
and and the proposed dormer window and
the rear extension would face onto
the rear garden of number 11
but there is
some 11 metres from the rear of the
proposed extension to the shared
boundary between the properties
and as stated
the proposed normal would contain
through windows with the middle one
being an ensuite so obscure glazed
and accepted that sorry
but given the full back position of the
ability to put a normal window in the
rear elevation
albeit without the roof being raised
and the distance separations distance
between number 11
and the rear dormer
as well as the orientation of the
properties
so it would not
that we're done we'll be in this
location here setting a little from the
edge of the
property as we can see
in this
drawing here is not considered
that there would be a direct impact
so significant warrant a recommendation
of refusal for the proposal so the
officer recommendation is for approval
albeit that
it is agreed there may be some potential
for overlooking
to number 11 given those
proposed first floor windows thank you
chair
uh thank you annabelle i move the
office's recommendation is adopted could
the vice chair please second or second
nature thank you council coleman cook
members
council robin
yeah thank you chair um
personally i'd like to go and have a
look at the site chair um
i'm listening to what's been said for
from the residents um
i think in this particular case
it doesn't look particularly
good from the rear
and so i want to have a look at that and
i'd like to see
i want to see the impacts of the
adjoining promises on this current one
on on this on the application site
because again there was a high building
to one side
um
so i would like to i
would propose a site visit here
i'll come back to you in a moment
council royal and thank you councillor
ghana
yeah thank you uh just
to
echo council auburn's point i totally
100 agree with him on this occasion as i
do on a number of occasions thank you
i won't comment on that counselor of
course you would counsel heart
hey i mean
i think this is unfortunate situation
this one because if if we go against the
approval
they can still do exactly the same thing
without raising the roof
um so
it's a no-win situation for number 11
regardless um and being that in mind i
mean i don't think our site visit will
make any difference because the owner of
the property is just going to put one in
regardless and under promising
development so i can't really see what
we're arguing about really to be fair
thank you thank you did i see uh
councilman uh paul moore
yes thank you chair it is paul moore yes
um
i i agree with uh my fellow colleague
here
if permitted development allows them to
do that anyway
they're still going to get what they
want and you know at the end of the day
they're going to get something slightly
different but they're still going to get
what they want um the only thing i would
suggest is that maybe you put a
condition on it that they add some
screening for number 11 at the at the
rear um which possibly may be a
condition but that we're not we can't
impose that because only looking at
what's in front of us but maybe they
could go back and discuss that with
number 11 maybe some additional
screening
for for their concerns but i don't think
a site visit's going to really help
you've got a tall building to one side a
dormer to the other and they can do it
under primitive development anyway thank
you chair uh thank you for that cut some
more
i just want to come back on one point
about the pd fallback um they are
obviously proposing to increase the roof
in this occasion so the dorm window is
effectively higher than anything that
could be built on the premise
development so it's just important to
make that distinction that there is a
consideration there that's that's
necessary to make about whether or not
this is
an increase in overlooking above
anything that could be done under pd so
i think just wanted to make that
distinction thank you
thank you did i see
council rusevski did you no
just no i i mean
the two points raised one by council
auburn go and visit this site yeah i
i agree with that i think maybe we
should go and have a look at the site
but also the permitted development point
is a very good
point because they will get most of what
they want through permitted development
thank you councillor zesky council you
want to come
thank you chair so just go back on ian's
point um
what is the difference between
permitted development height of the
window compared to that that would be uh
allowed under
this one
um to be approved of um are we talking a
couple of inches six inches are we
talking sort of three or four feet
can you
um i i can't give the precise
measurement from uh but i think it's
important to just outline the plan if if
i might instruct animal to possibly
change back to the other plan to the
existing because because the ridge is
increasing um where the body of any
dormal window in this instance would be
its effect you know has increased and
obviously you've been what you've been
able to get in
uh is if you could go to the proposed
sorry
is um
is to effectively
raise anything that could be under
permissive and up
is about half a meter i think it is
quite you know it's more and it's higher
so i think
what officers have looked at in this
instance is
the relationship between the two
properties especially it's awkward
because of the way number 11 is
perpendicular so you know you've always
going to create some overlooking with
anything that goes in that roof space
you obviously have got the property to
one side which obviously is two story
and does have a roof terrace at first
floor level but that doesn't offer
direct views so it's a combination of
factors it's the relationship with the
existing property next door as well as
the potential to to act under permitted
development to create and put windows
into that roof slope
those things in combination but the
reason i raised the distinction earlier
is because it's not it's not as
straightforward as saying well they
could definitely they can't do this
under permitted development i think
that's the important thing so this does
in its in its you know in terms of what
you're seeing on the screen that
relationship still needs to be
considered even when there is a fallback
in our view that they could put windows
in that roof slope thank you chair
thank you
chair just to come back so it'd be
windows under permissive development
rather than doors
um i i personally think i haven't tested
this i personally think it would it
would be a struggle to get the the
height of the door in there but i don't
have that information so i can't speak
to that in detail so i think members
just need to consider what is in front
of them in in this instance to be able
to see whether or not there's an issue
obviously i have heard mention obviously
of a site visit to look at that
relationship as well which obviously is
noted
uh thank you ian um i'm looking at
members of council crittenden
um yeah i
on paper and so to speak i like the look
of this
uh i am hearing though the issue about
the lack of communication
and i think that is particularly
something that has really brought us to
where we are
and i would be quite happy to go with
the site visit that would enable us to
just double check out that difference
between the permitted development and
what we've got in front of us and
hopefully give them some time to talk to
each other
thank you councilman and any other
members wish to speak
before i put this
to yourselves
and that's what is in front of us at the
moment before so
if you could please in those in favor of
the
application could they please show
there was against
abstentions
sure i thought you'd gone to sleep there
for a minute
that falls
therefore
um on listen as we have done listen to
a consultant and
um
counsellor i'm going to propose that we
have a site visit
to this property and i would like a
second for that please which i have
council at auburn
those in favor please show
anyone against
thank you very much we have a morning
out on the third of december thank you
very much members
sorry chad can i just confirm what time
that will be 9 30.
i may have to miss that i'm afraid
it's my first dental appointment for two
and a half years
i hope hope it comes out all right right
that concludes uh the public speaking
and therefore i'm going to ask our clerk
james to read out remaining planning
applications if there is a member
wishing to reserve one of those
applications could they please
um
show their hand please
james
chair so the remaining three
applications are 5a which is for
approval land on the east side of 119
king street ramsgate
5d again for approval which is the west
cliff terrace mansions at pegwell road
ramsgate
and 5e for approval 14 osborne terrace
margate thank you
uh thank you james i didn't see any
hands
in the air there so
therefore could i have a proposer
to move those applications
please
counselor alban
thank you could i have a seconder
take your pick james do members agree
thank you members um
that's it
i've been kicked if i'm wrong members
thank you very much your attendance
tonight
and you can watch it all over again on
youtube channel take care going home as
always and stay safe thank you officers
thank you
you